[Music]  mr wayne  you know you really could be doing more  for this city  your family has a history of  philanthropy but as far as i can tell  you're not doing anything  if i'm elected i want to change that  thank you  oh my god  i'm gonna go pay my respects will you  wait for me i'm gonna continue this  [Music]  excuse me chief can i talk to you  [Music]  guilt colson is missing what  he hasn't been heard from since last  night  christ not again hey  mr wayne  [Music]  you got people looking for him jim  sent a couple guys to his house nothing  what did his wife say she hadn't heard  from him  [Music]  [Music]  so  get back down  [Applause]  get out of the car and show your hands  get out  christ it's colson  there's a bomb around  [Music]  let's clear this place out now  the batman raided pg-13 experienced it  in imax only beaters march 4th  [Music]